Ok, so thulium is a very expensive lanthanide.
It’s very expensive
because it’s very hard to separate it from
its neighbours. The lanthanides
from the left to right undergo this contraction
where they get smaller
and smaller and over on the right-hand-side
at this point that they are all
of a very similar size. Now we can separate
them now but it is quite
difficult to do and therefore quite expensive,
so thulium is not used very
often. However thulium, as well as being able
to obtain the plus-3
oxidation state, it is also one of those ones
which can obtain the plus-2
oxidation state, which means that chemists
are now beginning to find
uses for it which they hadn’t expected before.
So you may see the use
of thulium increase in years to come. Because
it’s very hard to isolate
because it’s of a very similar size to its
neighbours, it took a guy called
Charles James, in 1911, a famous 15,000 times
of recrystalization to
isolate thulium in a pure, albeit as a chloride,
but a pure nonetheless,
compound for the first time.